Scott Disick is doing his best to quote
stay out of any trouble or drama as his
ex Kourtney Kardashian and Travis Barker
are quote more in love than ever we're
just you know living our best lives and
yeah a source sells E.T that Scott who
shares three children with Courtney has
been quote chill and low-key lately and
he's focused on being quote a great dad
I mean I think you just gotta figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day on the other hand courts
got love and babies on the brain
I do love being a mom I think having
that experience with Travis would just
be incredible the store sells easy that
when it comes to Courtney's marriage
with Travis her friends and family have
never seen her so smitten before quote
everyone is really happy for her she's
in a great chill place and it really
shows the source adds that quote Travis
and Courtney would still love to have a
baby together but they are taking things
day by day they are so supportive of
each other and are really enjoying every
moment of their relationship and married
life it's a beautiful thing now back to
Scott while we haven't seen him on
screen with court and Travis this season
he did make his season 2 debut last week
with Kendall when they had a brief chat
about real estate I more so want to flip
like I don't want to start from
scratching so you want to refurb yeah
Scott's appearance came a week after
Courtney revealed that she wasn't happy
that her ex played such a big role in
her engagement to Travis Barker on the
Family's reality show last season I
remember when you and Travis got engaged
and it was so exciting
and there was that you know a lot about
Scott's reaction how he's feeling like
you were a little upset about that I was
upset that they
chose to take my fairy tale and like
include
that part of it you'll remember after
Travis went all out and proposed to
Courtney last October
[Music]
on the show her sister Chloe met up with
Scott to see how he was doing a moment
that rubbed Court the wrong way don't
get me wrong
I'll always love your sister so I wasn't
that caught off guard I mean I thought
that I'd already been married the way
that she was talking so it wasn't crazy
thank God because at another time in my
life if I would have heard that life
would have been over for me do I think
it just bothered me because I felt
like this is
my fairy tale and I was like why can't
we show The Happy The Happy Ending why
do we have to focus on this and I get
it's TV and blah blah blah the reasons
but
to me I was not having it I was like you
wouldn't do this to anyone else A source
told ET back in May that Courtney is
quote emotionally done with Scott and is
putting all her focus on newlywed life
with Travis I feel like I am living like
a fairy tale
making like new memories and new moments
and I don't necessarily want Scott at
all of them
thank you
[Music]